The joe rogan experience most because he enjoyed it.
It was just barely breaking even.
But it's probably one of those toy stores where it was mostly like puppets and
like,
like you know,
educational toys and it wasn't like Gi joes and they had everything.
They had a lot of stuff.
They had regular like action figures for comic books and stuff like that.
What are you doing?
I just [inaudible] there's this documentary on Netflix right now called the toys
that made us,
and it's very interesting and like you learn so much like a,
showed the history of Barbie Barbie started off as a hooker.
Like it was a hooker doll.
The in Germany.
Come on.
Yeah,
swear to God.
Like they uh,
Google please.
Yeah,
there was this true,
the Barbie doll.
There was a doll that looked exactly like Barbie that they used to guys used to
like carry around and give to women.
And it was like a way of like,
uh,
a flirting with a woman like,
Hey,
I,
this is what I want to see you wearing later.
And so this,
uh,
person came over to Germany and saw this doll and modeled Barbie right after
this hooker doll.
And so if you look at the original Barbie,
but what it was modeled off of it,
it was just like a creepy looking hooker checking.
I'm sure you can find a picture of a,
but this documentary is so amazing cause it goes through like all the famous
enters your mind.
We like,
I just definitely gonna look into the history of Barbie and no,
it's just a documentary.
It just goes through the toys,
the toys that made us,
it's so good.
And it goes through like Heman and GI.
Joe Gi Joe is interesting because you know that back in the day,
you know,
releasing a guy doll like,
no,
we're not gonna make no guide.
All,
no one's going to play that.
But Gi Joe ended up being like one of the biggest toys in the whole entire
world.
That's why you had to call in an action figure.
I used to have a Steve Austin,
$6 million man action figures.
You had to call it an action figure them.
And that's where action figures came from.
Gi Joe.
That was the way around the doll thing.
Yeah.
Smart move.
Because dolls,
yeah,
dolls are not for boys.
Not Funny,
but you could have dinosaurs,
right?
Raw.
What does that sort of doll?
It's a doll.
It's a dinosaur.
A doll.
One of them was,
which one was it?
Not Gi Joe.
One of those was like a,
they made a whole cartoon and just made a toy.
He man.
Yeah.
It was just designed as a marketing tool.
They decided how do,
how are we going to fight star wars toys?
And they're like,
let's make it bigger and stronger.
So if you see a he man doll next to his star wars twice,
like,
well here's this little pussy doll,
you know,
so,
and then they made a cartoon around it and uh,
it's really interesting.
Like you wouldn't think it would be that interesting.
But even the Barbie part,
it was like,
wow,
this is fascinating.
And how they changed barbies.
Look every year,
like nadir sexier made her like her waist.
Like she gets so much shit because her waist is really small.
And like stuff.
That's because when you put clothes on for it to fit and look right,
that's how they had to make her waist just,
it was more for like the style of the clothes she was wearing,
not of what it looked like.
It was more like just to have the doll work right it,
it's really cool.
It's got to be fucking super hard to be a check and look at like those dolls and
look at your body and go,
what in the fuck?
This is not impossible.
Yeah.
You know,
cause a lot of those dolls,
they're not possible.
Well,
what's really funny is one of the things in the fifties
what does he say?
There is the only dog.
Yeah.
The build Lilli doll or something by literally dog can be bought and tobacco
shops,
bars and adult themes.
Toy stores,
Gerber rights.
Men got Lily Dallas's gag gifts at bachelor parties,
put them on their car dashboard,
dangled them from the rear view mirror or gave them to girlfriends as suggestive
keepsake.
What does that mean?
Suggestive keepsake.
Hey look at this,
but I want to say,
wow.
This prodo Barbie was just shy of a foot tall with bulging breasts and platinum
blonde ponytail made up for a night on the town with red puckered lips and blue
eyeshadow.
Wow.
Interesting.
The Journal,
German dolls,
heavy makeup and suggestively arched eyebrows didn't carry over to the American
version.
That's interesting,
Huh?
They tried to lighten it up a little.
Yeah.
Then they even go into like how her eyes are looking to the side,
not right at you.
Neat you.
If she could fuck you in this alley.
Yes.
To becoming,
Oh God,
they're dead comics for this little adult.
To what?
Your comic.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Lily was witty,
irreverent and sexually uninhibited.
One stripped summarize by Lord,
who's Lord.
Lord of the writer.
The writer.
Okay.
Shows lily covering her naked body with a newspaper explaining to a friend.
We had a fight and he took back all the presence he gave me.
Get it.
She's naked.
Another shows Lilly in a bikini.
When a police man tells her that two piece swimsuits are illegal,
she says,
oh,
and in your opinion,
which part should I take off that dirty bitch?
One interesting thing too is like,
you know how Barbara gets so much shit for him?
You know,
I like being a fatter woman,
having a,
you know,
the body issues and stuff like that.
Shit.
There was like a workout Barbie and she had a little scale and the scale was,
had a sticker on it and it was stuck at 110 pounds.
And then there was also a book that came with it,
like a cookbook or,
or like a book that's like how to lose weight on the back.
It says,
don't eat instead of that
dude that's dark.
Yeah.
Okay.